okay today I'm going to talk about
trends in energy resource use in the UK
we're going to start by seeing the
current situation of their energy
resource use we're going to see the
future and then we're going to think
about any problems with the transition
in our energy resources okay
so first of all let's have a look at the
current situation in the UK what is
happening with our energy resource use
so first of all it's important to think
about how our use our use of electricity
has changed over time so if I have this
quick graph to show you the UK
population over time we've seen an
increase in people in the UK so
increased population that has resulted
and over the 20 20th century of an
increase in use of electricity in demand
for electricity so currently where does
our electricity come from in the UK now
the majority of our electricity still
comes from fossil fuels so that is coal
oil and natural gas so this is currently
where where most of our electricity is
actually generated from some as well
from nuclear and some from renewable
energy but most of them on most village
duty comes from fossil fuels now the big
issues associated with fossil fuels
first of all they released co2 carbon
dioxide which can contribute towards
global warming so this is obviously a
problem they also release so2 sulfur
dioxide that contributes towards acid
rain so as we could see the current
situation we're producing lots of these
pollutants now another big problem is if
we have a look again at a little graph
just to show the stores and reserves of
fossil fuels that vary they're available
globally because they are non-renewable
they are starting to run out we are when
when we burn coal oil and natural gas we
can't just make more of it so it's
non-renewable so that is another problem
that we are going to have to face in the
future because we're going to have a
lack of these different resources these
different non-renewable energy sources
so now let's think about this what is
going to happen or what needs to happen
in the future so in the future in the UK
there'll be a move towards more
renewable energy sources so I'm just
going to do a quick example of one here
which is just a quick diagram of a a
wind turbine so there's lots of
different types of renewable energy such
as hydroelectric tidal barrages solar
cells wind power there's actually a
whole video I've done about renewable
energy sources now the good thing about
them are as follows first of all by
using renewable energy we produce less
carbon dioxide so therefore there'll be
fewer problems associated with global
warming less sulfur dioxide so therefore
have fewer problems associate with acid
rain and a big one as well is they won't
run out their renewable we could use
them again and again and again so unlike
fossil fuels that are running out
renewable energy sources we could use
again and again and again another
positive or another change we'll see in
the future in terms of vehicles that
also use fossil fuels we'll probably see
a massive rise in electric cars or
hybrid cars so these cars would would
would run on electricity opposed to
burning petrol which comes from oil so
these here are the changes that will be
be happening in the UK and already
there's a move to increase the amount of
renewable energy sources in the country
however these stages to get here from
the current situation is not as easy as
we may think so in the third section
we're just gonna have a look at
all problems that we might come across
as we try and make the transition to
using renewable energy resources so
first of all changes are expensive now
the big problem is if we have to build
all of these new renewable energy power
plants it's going to be really expensive
we already have the power plants set up
that burn the fossil fuels so building
new renewable energy plants is going to
be costly and that will come from
taxpayers money so it's not just as easy
as saying right we need to make this
change
another problem is location issues the
question is where abouts are we going to
build all these renewable energy plants
where am I going to build a
hydroelectric dam then we people who
will not want to live by these new
renewable energy plants so they might
complain and end up you know having a
big issue with it okay next up the
problem with a lot of renewable energy
it's issues with reliability for example
for wind power it's not always windy and
for solar power that requires the Sun
it's not always sunny the benefit of
fossil fuels is they're really really
reliable we have a constant source of
them and could constantly burn them so
there's no reliability issues now the
reliability of certain types of
renewable energy might get better in
time but that leads us on to the next
one so research takes time and money to
improve all of these different issues
the research takes time and money so
again it's not as straightforward as
saying these are ready to go now on a
large scale but it's going to take time
and money
also it's going to take money for people
to convert to electric and hybrid cars
because currently they're more expensive
so hopefully as research goes on the
price of these cars will come down but
at the moment not everyone could afford
electric and hybrid cars even though
they are better for the environment so
that basically sums up the trends in
energy resource use in the United
Kingdom thank you